[Musica]
bentrovati io vorrei portarvi in una
zona e che ho abitato molto molto spesso
probabilmente anche voi e dalla quale
sono quasi sempre fuggito
l'imbarazzo ecco l'imbarazzo questa
questa strana sensazione che proviamo
che proviamo con gli altri esseri umani
non ci si imbarazza mai da soli non è
però per per per spiegarvi ancora meglio
di che imbarazzo sto parlando vorrei
fare un piccolo esperimento allora
scegliete una una persona o alla vostra
destra sinistra davanti dietro
preferibilmente che non conoscete ma
anche se la conoscete va bene uguale
ok accoppiatevi nel senso metaforico del
termine ovviamente e al mio via
provate a guardarvi negli occhi ea
mantenere lo sguardo senza se senza
scappare insomma da quello sguardo siete
pronti
vi siete allora pronti via
ok stop shop ho detto stop anche ai due
signori si sono innamorati la ok allora
com'è andata
avete percepito quel leggera quel
leggero desiderio di scappare da quello
sguardo quel quel malessere quasi no
ecco proprio io vorrei parlarvi proprio
di quel imbarazzo perché ho scoperto che
in quelli imbarazzo
beh si nascondono delle potenzialità
pazzesche e grandissime e allora come mi
succede spesso quando trovo una parola
molto interessante cosa vado vado a
cercare l'etimologia della parola questa
questa attività che una volta era
dedicata insomma chi aveva una certa
cultura
adesso è molto semplice basta googlare
no la parola è normalmente ct risponde
wikipedia e così è stato allora o
googlato imbarazzo e wikipedia
mi ha detto imbarazzo in italiano e
deriva dallo spagnolo dallo spagnolo
antico e imbarazzo che vuol dire
ingombro ostacolo
allora mi sono detto ma ostacolo a cosa
prima che avete provato magari un
istante di imbarazzo e nello sguardo
dell'altra persona
c'è un ostacolo ostacola qualcosa che
vogliamo raggiungere ma che cosa stavamo
raggiungendo che cos'è che si è posta in
mezzo al l'imbarazzo che cosa cosa ha
ostacolato e allora così mentre mentre
appunto pensavo a queste cose insomma
nel mio studio lo è passata a mia figlia
marta la più grande e le domanda marta
sempi cosa ha scoperto
ho scoperto che è allora la parola
imbarazzo è presente in spagna e deriva
dallo spagnolo antico che vuol dire
ingombro ostacolo e lei
dall'alto della sua competenza
linguistica ma anche dal dall'energia
che i teenager hanno nello smontare le
nostre sicurezze da anziani mi dice papà
stai dicendo una cretinata e imbarazzo
in spagnolo vuol dire incinta una donna
imbarazzava è una donna incinta e in
quel momento passava anche francesca la
mia seconda figlia
questa è la sapevo anch'io e le guardo
mi sei brillano gli occhi le abbraccio e
devo ma voi siete dei geni ma grazie
grazie allora allora mi allontana un
attimo mi dicono mamma ha ragione
ha ragione la mamma sei proprio strano e
sono andati via ma io io sono rimasto a
a gustarmi questa cosa meravigliosa
perché allora sono andato a ricercare
ancora ma come è successo che gli
spagnoli sono passati da ingombro
ostacolo alla donna incinta e googlato
ma neanche loro lo sanno bene il perché
però me ne fregava niente perché a me
bastava questa metafora meravigliosa e
cioè prima nell'imbarazzo abbiamo
passato abbiamo provato quel malessere
no
ecco a me piace tanto questa cosa che
anche una donna quando scopri che si
incita a quel malessere o quelle nausee
allora noi abbiamo provato come se ci
fosse qualcosa che stava nascendo beh
anche anche quel malessere indicava alla
donna e indica alla donna che qualcosa
sta nascendo
allora ho preso la ho cercato la foto
dove c'erano marta e francesca col con
il pancione di questo imbarazzo però li
stava arrivando qualcuno
ma nell'imbarazzo che abbiamo provato
prima che cosa stava arrivando
beh è facile l'incontro l'imbarazzo si è
messo di traverso
all'incontro che stava avvenendo in
quegli sguardi degli imbarazzi che che
proviamo allora ancora più eccitato da
questa cosa adesso ha fatto un figurone
al ted dico tutte queste cose si è
presentata la mia terza figlia e mi ha
guardato che lei e anna che con i suoi
occhi a mandorla ha messo in imbarazzo
tutti ma veramente tutti è il ginecologo
il medico i parenti gli amici noi stessi
lei è specializzata nel mettere in
imbarazzo le persone non so bene come
succede ma se vado in giro con anna per
il centro della città
gli sguardi che incontriamo sono di
imbarazzo perché perché gli occhi a
mandorla di anna ci parlano della
sindrome di down
forse l'avete riconosciuta non è
orientale e proprio e l'asean umidità
per chi non lo sa è un cromosoma in più
cioè è l'anomalia genetica più comune
dell'essere umano cioè la maggior parte
di noi a meno che non ci siano persone
con sintomi da però abbiamo 46 cromosomi
anna e le persone con sintomi di tano
anno 47 cromosomi questo cromosoma in
più a tutti gli effetti collaterali
diciamo nelle persone che lo portano a
un ritardo intellettivo insomma che è la
parte più rompi diciamo di questo di
questo cromosoma però allora mi sono
chiesto ma perché quando c'è una
diversità
oppure la diversità percepita
l'imbarazzo diventa ancora più grande
e poi un'altra cosa perché
istintivamente scappiamo da questo
imbarazzo probabilmente anche prima
magari la tentazione di andare via con
lo sguardo
no perché scappiamo da quell imbarazzo e
allora la risposta me l'ha data un bimbo
un bimbetto piccolo eravamo a passeggio
io e anna e il bimbo era a passeggio con
la sua mamma incrocia lo sguardo di anne
la guarda bene dice mamma mamma ma
perché quella bambina agli occhi così
voi potete immaginare l'imbarazzo della
mamma che nessuna colpa la mamma e
l'imbarazzo di tutti anche il mio nel
senso cioè una domanda imbarazzante
anche se è assolutamente lecita normale
pulita perché ha gli occhi così e allora
la reazione della mamma è stata quella
non si dica queste cose
andiamo andiamo di andiamo via e sono
scappati no anna mi ha guardato e io ho
pensato ma allora ce lo insegnano a
scappare per insegniamo a scappare da
questa situazione di imbarazzo
allora è a quel punto mi sono detto ma
più l'imbarazzo è grande più
probabilmente l'incontro che si nasconde
dietro a questo questo sbarramento è
grande ma perché perdiamo questa
opportunità probabilmente quel bambino
in un'altra situazione di diversità non
avrebbe fatto più una domanda del genere
alla mamma perché l'avrebbe messo in
difficoltà e anzi riconoscendo
quell'imbarazzo e forse la strategia da
adottare è quella di scappare e allora
così impariamo a scappare
impariamo cielo insegniamo è a scappare
perché è un po faticoso e allora e
allora cosa abbiamo deciso io con anna
con le mie le altre mie figlie di di
tentare di rendere questa zona di
imbarazzo il più come posso dire
accessibile possibile perché c'è un
trucco semplicissimo che è il sorriso la
leggerezza il non prendersi troppo sul
serio anche negli incontri imbarazzanti
che abbiamo nella nostra vita
allora per fare questo abbiamo come
posso dire occupato il web con delle
cartoline e che dove anna ci vuole dare
alcuni messaggi per esempio questa è una
notizia che è venuta fuori sull'ansa
vera dove dicono facebook e instagram
down per un'ora e anna dice sì beh ma
che notizia è questa io sono dalla
nascita è mica faccio tutte ste storie e
questa è una cretinata
però però al merito di rendere quella
zona di imbarazzo dove la parola da o
anche così crea questo questo malessere
magari leggermente più accessibile
oppure quest'altra quando è uscito
l'iphone hicks voi sapete che la
sindrome di down appunto è una ics in
più
anna dice no scusate fatemi capire bene
vi spaventa tanto la nostra hicks in più
ora che cela life è una figata
e grazie
grazie anche perché anche perché adesso
non me ne vogliano ma se dobbiamo dirla
tutta il tè dx è un'anomalia genetica
perché l'originale è il ted a una ics in
più allora allora il mio
il mio invito è il nostro il nostro
invito è questo habitat e le zone di
imbarazzo abitate con il sorriso è
un'arma meravigliosa che abbiamo
usiamola abitate quelle zone di
imbarazzo perché scoprirete che in
quelle zone si nascondono degli incontri
veramente incredibili e quindi non mi
resta che salutarvi e augurandovi buon
imbarazzo e ora per non buttare via
anche diciamo l'esercizio che abbiamo
fatto prima e non buttar via gli
innamoramenti che sono nati è il momento
di scambiarsi il numero di cellulare
grazie di cuore
[Applauso]
[Musica]